[Music]
hi my name is bianca lambert and i am
cooking my aunt vivian's sweet potato
pie my aunt is the only person in our
family that still bakes sweets she's the
only person that's kind of carried this
recipe over from my grandmother and just
kind of passed down those southern roots
so the way that you will know your
potatoes are done you just kind of give
it a little poke or a little stab that's
how you know that it's ready i grew up
in atlanta and my parents are from this
town in alabama called monroeville so
thanksgiving christmas like whatever
holiday you can think of we would drive
down well my grandma i remember like she
would just always have all this food and
she didn't have a lot of money and all
that but you could guarantee
that there was going to be a spread
everything that you ever wanted she knew
all your favorites and that was her way
of showing love and i feel like that is
what southern cooking is all about it's
just a way to show love and and give
back to your family in a different kind
of way i'll say this i'm always looking
forward to this pie for thanksgiving and
christmas i might even volunteer to make
the sweet potato pie this year nobody's
probably gonna let me do it though or
they'll let me do like one and then
she'll do all the other ones
anybody makes anything good like if you
know something's really good at
thanksgiving it just goes so if you
don't get to that pie before it's gone
forget about it yeah you better get it
when you can
and people i mean we do shares very much
about community but people like what
they like we all know each other's
favorites so yeah once it's gone
that's it this is just one of my
all-time favorites it's it's the thing i
can eat i mean i can eat a whole pie by
myself so my aunt surprised me by
letting me know that she uses lemon
extract in
the sweet potato pie when she said it i
was like is she making a mistake but
it's been perfect for years so i'm sure
she knows what she's talking about
here's the thing i don't think anyone
can cook sweet potato pie like anybody
in my family nobody does it quite like
we do but hey to all the aunties and
grandmas and people out there like you
guys are amazing and i just think we're
all partial to our
family's cooking thanksgiving for us is
just like the best time of the year
probably my favorite holiday just
because it's so much about family and
food and eating and just having a good
time
it tastes so good
my aunt's gonna be super proud
[Music]
you